dr stephen strange you know him as a
world-renowned surgeon master of the
mystic arts and sorcerer extraordinaire
but do you know his whole story keep
watching for a rundown on doctor
strange's entire mcu timeline
the mcu is a universe filled with magic
but for the first few decades of his
life stephen strange is completely
ignorant of its existence all the way up
until his inevitable first encounter
with the mystic arts strange refuses to
buy into so-called fairy tales
preferring to believe what he can see in
front of him there is no such thing as
spirit
we are made of matter and nothing more
his steadfast devotion to science and
medicine alongside his exceptional
intelligence serves strange well and by
2016 he is one of the world's top
neurosurgeons and he likely stood at the
top for years as his skills and
notoriety even earned him a spot on a
hydra watch list at least as early as
2014. going further back we can play
strangers whereabouts during the 2012
chittori invasion of new york as part of
the time heist depicted in avengers end
game the hulk visits the sanctum
sanctorum in order to find stephen there
the ancient one tells holt that he's
about five years too early stephen is
currently performing surgery about 20
blocks that way
even then though the ancient one is well
aware of the man strange will soon
become
in 2016 strange's life is turned upside
down when a car accident costs him full
use of his hands seemingly ending his
career as a neurosurgeon broken and
dejected but still his head strong as
ever strange seeks out any and every
remedy for his condition after
exhausting all of his traditional
options he throws the ultimate hail mary
and flies to nepal following rumors of
miraculous healers in the hidden city of
kamatash there strange is forcibly
divested of his narrow concepts of
reality and begins studying magic in
earnest he approaches his magical
studies as he had his medical studies
accelerating the prescribed syllabus and
devouring every source of information he
can which leads him to develop a
relationship with a librarian sorcerer
wong during his studies strange also
becomes friends with the sorcerer mordo
masters the use of portals via the
magical sling ring uses the eye of
agamotto for the first time and learns
of the dangers inherent in the use of
dark magic
stranger studies come to an abrupt end
when the rogue sorcerer kaiselius
attacks the various magical sanctums
that guard the earth in his bid to
summon the dread dormammu between this
attack and subsequent battles much of
the groundwork for strangers
transformation into a true superhero is
laid the previous guardian of the
sanctum sanctorum daniel drum is killed
during these events and strange inherits
the position while battling kaiselius
and the sanctum the cloak of levitation
also chooses him as its new wearer most
importantly of all the ancient one dies
in combat with kaiselius leaving strange
as a new source for a supreme and
protector of the time stone his first
responsibilities are twofold stop
kaiselius and his rogue sorcerers from
bringing the dark dimension to earth and
defeat the evil dormammu with the aid of
wong mordo and the time stone strange
succeeds in both tasks and irritates the
heck out of dormammu at the same time
[Music]
dormammu
i've come to bargain
in 2017 strange first encounters the
asgardians thor and loki though only a
few months into his new role strange has
already begun compiling a list of
potential threats to earth and loki's
2012 attack on new york city earned him
one of the top spots when thor and loki
travel to earth in search of their
father odin strange detects their
unearthly presence and within a minute
has trapped loki in a self-contained
endless freefall leaving his card behind
for thor strange invites the thunder god
to the sanctum sanctorum once there thor
explains to strange his quest to locate
odin and strange's reply subtly implies
the level to which he is mastering his
new duties
i have to tell you he was adamant that
he not be disturbed your father said he
had chosen to remain in exile
in just a few sentences strange reveals
that he had dared to confront the old
father when he arrived on earth and that
their meeting was enough for strange to
earn odin's respect and confidence the
king of the gods trusted strange alone
with the secret a secret strange keeps
until the next king thor has need of it
after thorin his revenges defeat heller
on asgard thanos's ship sanctuary 2
ambushes the survivors as his last act
before being killed by thanos's black
order heimdall sends bruce banner to
earth specifically to the residents of
doctor strange banner warns strange of
thanos imminent rival on earth and thus
the infinity war begins strange is a key
player throughout accompanying iron man
and spider-man as they travel to
confront thanos on titan after joining
up with the guardians of the galaxy the
trio battles thanos who is by then in
possession of four of the infinity
stones strange plays perhaps the biggest
role in the fight not just an opposing
thanos but also in scanning alternate
futures to determine the single course
of events that will lead to the mad
titan's defeat at the end of this
confrontation strange gives up the time
stone to thanos a choice only he knows
is right
tony
there was no other way
the war against thanos ends with a blip
an event in which half of all life
disappears in a matter of moments in
several films and tv shows characters
explicitly state that the blip lasted 5
years as thanos blipped strange he spent
2018 to 2023 simply not existing those
who have blipped didn't notice the
passage of time at all and so to strange
one moment it was 2018 and the next it
was 2023 drawing strange's five-year
absence the remaining population of the
universe carried on and a few notable
events took place two are worthy of
particular notes as they undoubtedly
held a place of importance and strangers
tour of alternate futures first around a
month after the blip the remaining
avengers locate thanos and kill him but
not before learning that the infinity
stones are all destroyed the second
event takes place five years after the
blip when scott lang is finally freed
from the quantum realm and returns to
earth
lang's return and his first-hand
knowledge of the reality of time travel
kicks off the time heist which begins in
2023 after the avengers successfully
undo thanos's snap a younger version of
the mad titan attacks the avengers
compound here strange plays a crucial
role in his defeat knowing how the
entire sequence of events must play out
strange recovers from the blip faster
than most he quickly begins gathering
the blipped heroes from across the
galaxy as well as an army composed of
sorcerers asgardians ravagers and
wakandans using his mastery of portal
teleportation strange gathers all the
allied armies and heroes to avengers
compound leading to the final epic
showdown against thanos and his forces
during the battle strange reminds tony
stark that there's only one successful
path to victory the details of which
stark instinctively understands stark
seizes the stones and blips away thanos
and his armies sacrificing himself in
the process
[Music]
iron man
a few days later strange and wong
attends stark's funeral as the infinity
saga officially concludes soon after his
return to existence strange learns that
he is no longer the sorcerer supreme
since he had been non-existent for five
years the title had passed to wong in
what strange describes as a technicality
though no longer the earth's chief
sorcerer strange is still an exceptional
magician and comes to the aid of peter
parker when he needs a little magical
help in 2024 strange attempts to cast a
spell to conceal parker's secret
identity from the world thanks to
parker's interference however the spell
goes awry leading to a breakdown in the
structure of the multiverse due to
stranger's magic beings from other
universes begin crossing over into the
mcu's main earth and though he's no
longer the sorcerer supreme strange sets
out to hunt down these aberrations he
and parker disagree over the fate of the
multiversal beings leading to a lengthy
battle between the two that ends with
strange trapped in the mirror dimension
when he finally frees himself he returns
to earth fixes as much of the
multiversal damage as he can and finally
cast the original spell to make parker
anonymous once more
the disney plus series what if it's
unique in that it is firmly canonical in
the mcu but takes place in different
universes than the other movies and
shows the episode what if doctor strange
lost his heart inside of his hands
follows a version of strange who lost
his longtime love christine palmer
instead of his ability to perform
surgery this variant of strange tries to
fix that last with the same energy that
the prime mtu strange used to master the
mystic arts except this version is
burdened with far too much grief to
become the best version of himself his
quest brings him unparalleled power but
only through the use of dark predatory
magic and it soon leads to the near
annihilation of his own universe before
long though the ultimate strange has
been recruited to join the guardians of
the multiverse but this isn't the last
time mcu fans will be seeing a strange
variant
things just got out of hand
the events of spider-man no way home
take place in 2024 and the events of dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
are said to directly follow them as
strangers damage to the multiverse
during spider-man's adventure is what
kicks off the plot of his own sequel
movie however given that the hawkeye
series also takes place at the very end
of 2024 and never mentions any
multiverse level war or giant tentacle
monster it's possible that multiverse of
madness could be set later placing it in
early 2025. whether it's set in 2024 or
early 2025 multiverse of madness are
strangers most important quests yet even
the events of the infinity saga can't
compete half of the universe's
population sounds like a lot until the
fate of millions of universes are on the
line strange will encounter multiple
versions of himself in his next
adventure team up with a potentially
unstable scarlet witch meet the
multiverse hopping heroin america's
chavez and possibly even meet marvel's
infamous illuminati no matter what
happens however you can safely bet that
doctor strange's timeline is far from
over
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one